[Musique]
dans un des paysages bucoliques du bas
du fleuve à cacouna
il y as et goélands à la recherche de
matières organiques contenues dans ce
dépotoir et à quelques dizaines de
mètres de là cette curieuse usine c'est
une fierté parce que j'ai quand même
consacré plusieurs années de ma vie à ce
projet lors cette usine c'est un peu le
bb de serge forest construite au coût de
26 millions de dollars en 2015
elle est unique en son genre en plus de
traiter le biogaz qu'on produit par
biométhanisation
on traite aussi le méthane qui se dégage
du lieu d'enfouissement technique donc
le dépotoir
alors la biométhanisation comment ça
marche
[Musique]
tout commence ici avec cette collecte de
déchets organiques
les fameux déchets de table que les
résidents mettre dans leur fameux
backdrop rendez-vous maintenant à l'
usine pour transformer tout ça en biogaz
pour nourrir cette usine il faut des
matières organiques qui vont être broyés
par une mâchoire géante
une fois bien broyer il faut préparer la
digestion de cette matière
il faut donc de la salive et dans ce cas
ci c'est dans le milieu acide de
l'hydrolyse heures que ça se passe la
mixture est chauffée à 55 degrés est est
ensuite transféré danse et estomac
gigantesque le digesteur essai de ces
tests au mas que va sortir le fameux
biogaz
il reste alors deux étapes finales
purifier le gaz est ensuite le rendre
liquide en le refroidissant à moins 160
degrés pour pouvoir le transporter
premier avantage c'est qu'on détourne la
matière organique de l'enfouissement
ensuite on produit un carburant qui vont
remplacer un carburant de sources
fossiles et ont produit un fertilisant
valorisant milliards
ce fertilisant qu'on appelle le digestat
permet aux agriculteurs d'enrichir leur
sol bref un retour à la nature
j'ai de la misère à comprendre qu'on
continue en foyer de la matière
organique
c'est une ressource naturelle dans la
région seulement une personne sur trois
rempli son bac brun
pas assez de matière première pour
produire de grandes quantités de biogaz
depuis trois ans et demi l'usiné a
produit plus d'un million de mètres
cubes de biogaz
mais il est brûlé dans cette torchère
car après bien des tests pour purifier
et liquéfier le gaz ainsi que des bris
technique
le biogaz n'est toujours pas utilisable
comme carburant certain que les gens se
questionnent avec raison aussi
après après trois ans le monde se
demande d'abord ça va aboutir
mais si je ferais y croit beaucoup
je suis originaire de la madeleine il ya
20 ans on a senti l'urgence d'installer
la cueillette des matières organiques
certains m'ont dit oui c'est un millier
celui-là mais il reste que n'importe où
connaissent une grosse patassé c'est
quand même une île c'est une grosse
partie terre qui sont peut-être grande
vitrine planète le meilleur indice d'un
succès futur pour lui se trouve quelque
part dans ce dépotoir
car le jour où il n'y aura presque plus
de goélands il aura réussi une partie de
sa mission
[Musique]